c'est le président monsieur le ministre
Richard collègue je vois qui est un peu
d'énervement c'est normal la nuit avance
moi je pense qu'on est au bout du
système voilà je vous le dis
tranquillement je vais prendre une
minute je pense qu'on est au bout du
bout
49.3 l'Assemblée nationale ici
première partie moi j'ai pas fait
beaucoup enfin j'ai assisté à un truc là
sur la première partie ou la majorité
sénatoriale vote des amendements ajuste
raison gouvernement arrive dit bon voilà
c'est bien mais on va faire une deuxième
délibération c'est vous-même qui allait
porter ça moi j'ai vu des choses
incroyables des gens se lever et dire je
suis d'accord avec l'amendement que j'ai
défendu heureusement et je vais voter
contre la deuxième des marques et non
mais voilà on en est là pour équilibrer
les comptes puis après on passe à une
deuxième partie
c'est l'humiliation du Parlement je vous
le dis comme ça quoi tranquillement où
on n'a pas le temps de débattre enfin
bon on va pas se refaire dans ces
conditions là on va retirer tous nos
amendements ce qui est en ce qui
concerne notre groupe ce qu'on a même
pas le temps de les voter et puis bon
voilà je retire ensuite celui sur la
deuxième partie la ressens 6 retirer
mais franchement c'est pas une très
belle image du Parlement qu'on donne ce
soir et on vote qu'on la mission voilà
en ce qui nous concerne chacun faisant
ce qu'il souhaite après moi je pense
qu'il faut qu'on ait un vrai débat là je
pense que c'est le dernier budget qu'il
faut qu'on fasse comme ça et je pense
que c'est une urgence
démocratique là démocratique
parce que
honnêtement quand on nous regarde si les
Françaises et Français nous regardent
parce que ils sont outrés et chaque
parlementaire qui est ici quel que soit
60 sensibilités peut pas être satisfait
de ce qu'on vient de faire franchement
je vous remercie monsieur le président
[Musique]